I would say the most fascinating part
about saving that really motivates most
people and in particular young people is
this whole notion of compound growth now
you know we all learn this in our in our
math classes but what happens is is we
save a little money and then it earns
interest or return then our interests
and our in the amount we save starts to
grow itself and it just keeps
snowballing in fact i'll give you a
little a little example which is
unrealistic but it really shows compound
growth if you if you had a penny and it
doubled every day for 30 days that penny
would grow to over 10 million dollars
now certainly we are money doesn't grow
that quickly but if you show a young
person just even you know I'm having an
eight to ten percent growth rate the
amount of money that you will have in a
later age is really life-changing and
very motivating and so that I think
compound growth is really the key to
that which also the other key or
motivator is having options in your life
being able to do the things that you
otherwise never ever could do
well that again that's this whole
concept of compound growth that's you
know earning interest or or having
growth on your dollar and and so what
happens is the growth itself starts to
grow and earn income on it on it as well
so it's just again a snowball effect
where it grows and grows and grows
really fast similar to how that penny
grew and so saving today lets you know
today allows it to grow for more
tomorrow what we try to do is get the
word out to as many young people as
possible at Schwab we say if you're in
your teens or in your 20s save ten
percent of your income for the rest of
your life and you will be financially
secure but if you wait until your 30s
you're going to have to say fifteen to
twenty percent of your income and then
in your 40s we say ouch you know then
you're going to mean twenty-five percent
of your income that's pretty difficult
to do so the sooner you can start the
easier is on your pocketbook
you